there are many things that batman gets
right about its title character so
what's the deal with that super slow
walk keep watching to find out heads up
spoilers ahead
the caged crusader begins the film as a
terrifying creature of the night
instilling fear into the hearts of
criminals and everyday citizens alike
fear
is a tool however he realizes he needs
to be more than that by the end of the
movie he needs to be a symbol of hope as
much as fear
another aspect the film does
exceptionally well is establishing bruce
wayne as the world's greatest detective
that he's often referred to in the
comics he walks slowly around crime
scenes taking in every detail and when
he receives his first card from riddler
he's able to solve the riddle fairly
quickly he's met his intellectual match
but before he can bring riddler to
justice he'll go through the physical
and emotional ringer to realize what he
needs to become to stop him
it's unlike any other batman film that's
come before and some of the changes to
the character and setting have some fans
scratching their heads one of the most
significant changes involves the speed
at which batman enters a crime scene
many viewers have noted he walks
exceptionally slowly entering a room
this has caused quite a stir on social
media particularly on reddit however
many fans have chimed in with their own
theories as to why this batman is slower
than what we've seen on the big screen
before one reddit user posted a meme
reading batman in this movie walk slowly
when entering crime scenes so that his
lens can record and identify details
with greater clarity one of the newest
gadgets batman sports in the new movie
is a pair of high-tech contact lenses
that record everything the user looks at
it allows bruce to review the footage at
a later time so he can focus on some
more details he and the cops may have
missed the first time around he also
gives the lenses to selena kyle at one
point so that he can look at the
clientele deep within penguins club in
fact the same redditch user made a great
connection stating this is also shown
canonically when he requests selena to
move around a bit slower as he's
tracking everyone's face inside the
lounge of course others suggest the slow
walking goes even deeper a different
reddit user wrote it also makes him seem
even more inhuman and unnatural lends to
his terror hero status both explanations
ring true and it just goes to show the
level of detail director matt reeves
went into crafting a realistic world the
first conversation i had with matt about
it i just knew there was something
radically different from anything we've
seen in my movies before throughout his
existence batman has always sported an
array of gadgets to help him out of a
bind he may not have super powers but he
has plenty of help in other ways in the
batman he has a few familiar gadgets but
there are some new items as well that
assist him when he needs the most
arguably the most important gadget he
has at his disposal outside of the
contact lenses is the liquid he injects
himself with during the final battle
with ridler's henchmen it's never
established what precisely the substance
is some believe it was a mere adrenaline
sharp batman uses whenever he's too
decent and bruised to continue on his
own others think it was a variation of
bane's venom either establishing that
bane already exists in this universe or
that he could potentially come up down
the road one of the reddit users in the
latter category said i'm glad i wasn't
the only one who noticed the serum i
think they're setting up for bane his
reaction to it was very reminiscent of
how bane would react while much of his
gear has been seen in other iterations
of the character the batman adds some
intriguing wrinkles here and there to
make the machines more practical to this
particular version for instance batman
has seemingly always had a grappling gun
but this version springs out of his arm
for quick and easy access
perhaps another reason why batman walks
slowly is due to all the gear he has to
carry around with him check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]